Squad member Corey Bush making some very
controversial comments about people
opposing woke policies the Democrat
throwing gasoline on an already hot
issue watch this
when you say I'm anti-woke when you talk
about wokeness you're saying I'm
anti-black and I don't want black people
to speak up for themselves I don't want
equality and justice for black folks you
should be on the side of folks who are
woke because we're saying no more
oppression against our community unless
you are saying I'm racist white
supremacist and I'm bigoted
stop talking about wokeness and you
can't tell me that I'm wrong because I'm
from the very movement where this came
about don't let a fascist tell you what
being woke means
okay
um so it really comes down to this
question of what woke is and I I do
think that people Define it in in
different ways so Harold I wanted to ask
you first what do you think woke is and
is she defining it correctly
so I disagree with the congresswoman for
a couple of reasons first I have no clue
what woke is I hear people throw it
around and use it and I I've said it on
this show I believe that Republicans
talk about people being woke Democrats
think of everything it's toxic and then
they want to cancel it I don't even know
how to define all of those things
two
just because you disagree with me on an
issue doesn't make you racist I think
we've we've reached a point in some of
our politics and some of the political
conversations we have especially as
people get further and further away from
one another depending on the side of the
aisle they sit on that race quickly
almost reflexively gets invoked uh
whenever there's a political
conversation so I don't accept that
three I think the universal truth that
has to be embraced and has to be talked
about more is that we're all part of a
human race here and we can have
differing opinions be it climate change
we can have differing opinions uh be it
how we educate kids we should we can
have different opinions and likely
should about health care and how we pay
our bills as a country but we've got to
understand we're not going to get to
Solutions if we keep automatically
reflexively invoking race all the time
when it has no bearing or no relevance
to what we're talking so the
congresswoman I don't know but I
disagree with her you know it's going to
be an issue
USS Jesse because Rhonda Santos one of
the things that he
has deeply ingrained in all of his
beaches is that Florida is where woke
goes to die so she's painting it in this
light how do you see it
well if someone ever asks DeSantis to
Define woke he better have a good answer
yeah because it's not easy to Define it
succinctly
you notice that song Greg where it's
like you think this song is about Carly
Simon You're So Vain
she thinks woke's all about race it's
not there's so many other factors you
got the radical trans pronouns people
changing in locker rooms you got attacks
on masculinity attacks on capitalism
attacks on police attacks on traditional
value the new political correct sure
yeah but it's really an attack on my
ability to be judgmental you have to be
able to be judgmental in a society and
say this is morally wrong or this is
morally right because if you can't say
that then everything goes everything's
permissible and it's like cultural
relativism nothing's better nothing's
worse everything's just blah and that's
how civilized civilization does I do
agree with her that we have to stop
oppression but you don't stop oppression
by oppressing other people you don't
just bury all the straight white guys
and pee on their grave we can work
together to make other people successful
and she does have to acknowledge this
sometimes where people are is a result
of all the decisions that they've made
some people in society have to take
accountability for where they are in
society it's not because they're being
oppressed maybe it's something that they
have done or they have not done but we
do know that in the United States of
America the sky is the limit if you make
the right choices well that's the
argument judge that Tim Scott was making
and sunny hosston basically said to him
the litmus test is this do you believe
the country is systemically racist or
not right right you know it all comes
down to as everyone has been saying it
all comes down to race you know the
Demps need to stop acting like they own
all the black voters that because
um you're black you're definitely
agreeing with them I think one of the
interesting parts of this this segment
is that there there were Muslim children
in the schools who were allegedly or
claimed to be on the side of white
supremacists after they spoke against
the sexuality discussion materials in
the classroom and the the Muslim
children and their parents didn't want
to get involved in this transgender
nonsense and then they called them white
supremacists you should be with us you
should be woke so I guess it's not just
about race it's also about if you don't
agree with everything you say that we're
saying then you were white supremacists
if you don't agree with transgenderism
you're a white supremacist but they just
look Cory Bush herself is someone whose
business it is to divide she's the one
who initially wanted to defund all the
police she then used her own campaign
money for uh uh someone to defend her I
think it was her husband that she gave
campaign money to to Defender and he's
not a security guy yeah
um you know it's like everything for me
is the way I want it and you don't
matter but they're wrong they're just
wrong
right well I I have to commend Harold I
thought your answer was like dead on
perfect and within it you defined it the
wokism succinctly which is seeing
everything through the prism of race
because if you look through the prism of
race and it's oppression politics one's
an oppressor one's the oppressed the
interesting thing about it though is
anti-woke it's not anti-black it's
anti-stoop I mean it's
anti-workers anti-stupid and stupidity
knows no color because and you notice
this the loudest wokest people aren't
black right they're right they're white
female liberals and I I mean this is my
opinion only I don't have the science
although I probably could find it uh I
think it's replaced a certain like
amount of meaning in their lives this is
a replacement for maybe a lack of
religion or a lack of family and that's
why clinging to wokism is so is is so
important but if you it's like what the
judge said you look at Armenian families
right you look at Muslim parents black
parents they're all pissed off they
don't want their kids joining some Neo
Marxist cult they don't want the sisters
or perverted Indulgence you know strip
it in their classrooms it's why you got
to look really hard to find a a black
mug shot in any file on Auntie antifa
they're all really miserable white
people who had lousy relationships with
their parents and are just troubled
people wokeism is in my opinion
anti-black
because it relies on this power Dynamic
model oppressor versus oppress and I
can't imagine a worst mindset for
Success because no matter what you do
there's always going to be somebody to
blame but you and that is not a winner
that's a loser if everywhere you look at
somebody else's fault you are a loser
yeah blame yourself being woke is an
excuse yeah I went on Brian kill Mead I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now